another contentious contest is in Ohio
correspondent Ellison barber is in
Cleveland tonight Jim Rene see I have
hundreds of pages of his lawsuits he's a
bully he's a wealthy guy who bullies
people with lawsuits it's time he gets a
little bit of his own medicine less than
24 hours before polls in Ohio open and
the top Republican Senate candidates are
involved in a lawsuit
they've taken exactly what I am
investment banker and Senate hopeful
Mike Gibbons is suing his Trump endorsed
opponent Congressman Jim Renee C Gibbons
claims earn AC has falsely accused him
of being pro-choice anti Trump and
ideologically flexible in court
documents Givens says he has suffered
quote harm to his reputation emotional
distress exposure to contempt ridicule
shame and damage to his business and
candidacy and that in making the
defamatory statements Renee C acted with
actual malice and is thus responsible
for punitive damages Gibbons is asking
the court for 1 million dollars today
congressman Renee C is at his campaign
office in wodsworth Ohio and seemingly
unfazed by the lawsuit mr. Kidman's has
decided to do something that's kind of
unusual in in politics but it is what it
is my big concern is really the people
of Ohio and making sure that we move
forward and get the right message out do
you think there's any validity to the
lawsuit look one thing I can tell you
I've I've never been in politics tone 7
years ago and I learned people can say
anything about you I've had that done to
me in free elections in the past in the
end you just got to have tough skin and
move forward and I think he's he'll have
to learn that in the future
whoever wins tomorrow will challenge
incumbent Democrats senator sherrod
Brown
according to Fox News analysis the race
leans Democrat it's not quite a toss-up
but definitely not a solid blue
Gibbons filed the paperwork for that
lawsuit on Thursday he says even if he
loses tomorrow he will not withdraw the
lawsuit Brett I was Barbara live in
Cleveland Elson thank you